so it's not urban legend that that's
what you did that's what you did
hey guys I'm off the grid for August but
here's a generic intro to a clip we
wanted to show you when I was doing The
Tonight Show I
I was making 30 million a year it was
ridiculous okay and NBC said well we're
gonna have to kind of half the crew
you know so we had a big meeting I said
all right bro show hands how many fail I
should take a 50 pay cut so we can keep
everybody well I got out and voted
that's why I got screwed on that one but
really
I already have 15 million dollars I'm
doing pretty good you know I never
thought I'd get this far and you know
something they were the best crew for
the rest of the days
you know everything was always terrific
with the Union crew Everybody made a
good living you know guys who come up
and show me the car they bought or the
house they got around the corner or
whatever it might be and
it didn't cost me anything really
because I had plenty money I was making
plenty of money what year did you take
the haircut from 30 to 15.
it was in the 2000s maybe 2000
five from that point on I think they uh
the legend is is that you always kept
all those tonight's show checks oh yeah
and made your money doing live
performances yeah corporate things and
stuff like that yeah you got to be
hungry I I I I live on I I like I used
to live week to week did you literally
just put those checks you know in the
bank and I read the money I made as a
stand-up yeah I I wanted to be a
comedian I never thought TV was a job
that would last you how many years did
you do that until the very end I never
touched any of it I always worked so I
was doing 210 dates a year no I listen I
know what you can get paid if you go out
and you sprinkle some corporate gigs in
there there's money to be made oh yeah
but uh you still have a pretty big nut
you have guys who work for you you
purchase a car every once in a while
yeah yeah uh fly sort of private in that
you have to Reef fuel in Muncie Indiana
every once in a while can get all the
way across the country but the the money
just went into an account
yeah still there still there yeah and um
so how do you what do you think of this
so it's not urban legend that that's
what you did that's what you did no but
I mean I'm not
I don't have girlfriends and cocaine
habits and stuff like that you know so
you can save a tremendous amount of
money did um how do you reconcile the
sort of comedic mind with the mechanical
mind because it's not a
seems like it's not a coincidence to me
that most The Comedians I know have zero
sort of tangible life skills you know
they they seem to be fairly inept but
also mainly just not interested in cars
and construction and mechanics and I
sort of have you pegged as kind of a
mechanical guy even more than a car guy
well you know that's not really true I
mean Tim Allen very much that way well
you can find exceptions but I'm saying
like by and large yeah I think I think
you're right most of those guys it's a
genetic flaw that makes you a comedian
it's not a plus we just happen to live
in an era when it pays dividends I mean
if this was The Crusades it would be why
are the soldiers laughing
who's making him laugh kill that guy you
know and that's yeah because it's
annoying just kill that guy just kill
him right now because they're not paying
attention but we live in a time now well
now I have this happens to be very good
dividends so that's pretty lucky but
I mean I find most communities either
just off the wall drunk coke heads crazy
or complete abstain I rarely find
anybody in the middle you know don't you
find that to be true too
yeah I mean comedians
maybe there's something to the fact that
they're trying to construct and connect
things all the time in their head I
recently had a person say to me when I
said I get home I just want to watch TV
I just I I watch and people say like
what do you watch like an old episode of
Starsky and Hutch and they go why
because I just want to sit there and the
person said that's because your your
brain is trying to connect things all
day and then you get home and you don't
want to connect things but I'm wondering
if
sometimes comedians think a little too
much I mean you well I think
this is silly saying but the hardest
healthiest when the head and the hands
work together